I am a massive fan of the Bourne movies
I think we all are I just absolutely
love those movies it's really nice cuz I
enjoyed them all so much and now my son
is an age where he and I we're watching
them together and he's seen him for the
first time and he's absolutely hooked
that's great and so we're watching it
and the action is so amazing and then I
read somewhere that you're afraid of
heights and I thought that's not
possible because I've seen you do too
many cool stunts where it looked like
you couldn't possibly be afraid of
heights
yeah I didn't know that I was afraid of
heights too I mean I did these stunts
like I jumped off a bridge in the Bourne
in the second Bourne movie and now I was
fine I was wearing a cable I know I had
a cable and a harness it was a big crane
that I was attached to I was like this
is fine and I and I did it and but I I
was in Dubai in 2004 and and went to the
top of this building with my wife and on
this helicopter pad and walked out and
and it was one of those I went full
lizard brain and I realized oh my god
you mean you just froze I completely
froze I couldn't I was like I couldn't
physically move it was crazy and right
and I subsequent like subsequent to that
I haven't done anything really that
involved Heights but I did I had so I
had dinner with Tom Cruise like years
ago after he did that thing out out of
the building yeah that may be so many
insane he's done so many insane we hung
off a plane and he hung off the plane
and he's hanging he's running down
buildings like it's absolute at once oh
I saw that one and I and I and I ended I
happen to have dinner with him Emily
Blunt was making a movie with him a
really good movie called edge of
tomorrow that I did years ago and I was
in London and and and we all had dinner
together and so I I kind of cornered him
and I said hey tell me about this like
I'm afraid of heights how did you do
this thing and he goes oh I you know and
he's you've met Tom he's very like
you're the only person in the world when
everything else yeah yeah it's you right
in the eye it's not even that everything
else disappears for him everything else
disappears for you like it's just
everything else went away and suddenly I
was like falling in love it's good
it could be it could be but I know
exactly what you're talking about yeah
but he just laser locked and he was like
cuz he really wanted to talk about he
said I've been dreaming of this shot for
15 years of this sequence and finally I
had a chance to do it and I goes well so
how did it come to pass and he goes ok
ok so I go to the safety guy I tell this
one I'm gonna do this one I'm gonna
explain the whole the whole the whole
gag to him right the safety guy says you
can't do that because that's too
dangerous and I'm like uh-huh uh-huh and
he goes so I get another safety guy I'm
tapping out cuz you win you are the best
at that point when you get to set the
safety guy yeah whose only job is to
keep you safe yes says that's too
dangerous yeah my reaction is too bad we
can't do that sequence I came up with it
we've been really cool right his
reaction is no we're getting another
safety yeah you're out you're out
service guy Samy safety chef
have you ever done safety on a movie
nope no the first time probably my last
yeah I told mr. Cruz he could run off
the top but he said he could do it I
believe Cruz just laser lock I'm the
guys to my world just disappeared and
I'm in love and yes you can jump off he
could turn to taking some people he's
that good
[Applause]